I've with David thanks so much for
coming to do this thanks for having me
you're a busy man you are writing books
and also the finance editor I think you
know what I was the finance editor until
about a week ago okay and then I got a
new job at the Times which is I'm the
business investigations editor at The
Times now that sounds more important
well now they're both important it's
more it's better suited to my skills at
the basically we're like maybe you'd be
more comfortable in this role all right
so you've done a whole bunch of stuff
you've worked at The Wall Street Journal
New York Times and I can't want to go
through just the work you've done before
getting to New York Times in the recent
book that you wrote dark towers and then
we can get into what is an epic story
but just kind of what did you do pre
getting to other times so I'd been at
the Wall Street Journal for about a
decade
in New York and then London and back in
New York and that was kind of my crash
course it actually worked at Dow Jones
Newswires before that but I had the
formative years my career were at the
journal writing with banking finance all
sorts of shenanigans all over the world
why the interest in finance and banking
like if you're a reporter there's a
whole bunch of [ __ ] you can write about
but like why is that so interesting to
you you know it's funny it it wasn't
really I got into it I had started
covering politics out of college because
I was fascinated by politics and that's
kinda the most glamorous thing to do in
journalism and it turned out for someone
straight out of college like myself it's
very hard to find decent jobs and
especially ones that pay so I wasn't a
job that was like paying $15,000 a year
my paychecks would bounce I'd no health
insurance and I needed a new job and it
turned out there are live jobs we had in
business journalism and so that's what I
gravitated toward and I was not
interested in it at first like I've got
interested in it and one of the reasons
is that it's there's just kind of a
symmetry and kind of it's almost like
math like you can kind of like their
puzzles to actually untangle that have
real answers which I found really
satisfying you can see reactions to your
stories in the stock market it's
something that's tangible and real and I
really like that yeah and so what it's
like the process
for when you're looking at all these
different stories you could go write
about like how do you choose which ones
end up being I'm gonna go spend a lot of
time and really resources and pursuing
this versus yeah that's interesting but
that's not a story for the New York
Times or Wall Street Journal or wherever
you're looking it just really depends I
mean there's you I mean they're kind of
multiple ways to look at it one is just
if something is big and in the news and
has news value you're gonna cover it and
if there's if you're on a beat and I was
at the Journal for example I was from
2007 to 2010 I was the beat reporter
covering Citigroup and that was a moment
during the financial crisis where
there's a tremendous amount of news and
so you would basically anything to
dealing with citigroup's kind of rapid
unraveling was something I would write
about as in quieter times you want to go
over the stories that not only you think
will have impact and resonate with
readers but also things that in my case
I was passionate about and cared about
and found really interesting and there's
there's nothing worse than working a
story you don't care about and in part
B's is boring and that's so if you the
writer and reporter are not interested
in a story that shows very clearly to
readers and no one's gonna read it yeah
so you've broken a ton of stories over
the last couple of years when it comes
to the finance world but before we get
into that I want to have you break a
story here on Wikipedia which is if
somebody goes to your Wikipedia page
they see all kinds of cool facts about
you but some of them may not be as true
because people might be confused yeah
its Wikipedia I mean anyone who's
watching this who knows me knows they've
heard this a million times but it's like
the bane of my existence there's someone
a long time ago actually let me just at
the outset state well I told you earlier
which is that I have never edited
created deleted ever touched anything on
Wikipedia including my own page
but there someone created a Wikipedia
page for me a long time ago and since
then it's built into this very big and
kind of unnecessarily and unwarranted
very detailed thing about my life
including just some stuff that's not
true like I think it calls me an
accomplished French horn player so yeah
so it literally says that you're I think
experienced French horn player I
it's not experience because I am you
could if you could argue that that is
true because from like grades I don't
know like two to six maybe
I played the French horn and I think I
was like pretty good is great let's say
accomplisher right yeah it was grades
two to six I was like pretty good as
French let's go but I stopped and by no
reasonable and I haven't played and what
thirty years or something and I
certainly like was not accomplished by
easy win awards or anything in sixth
grade you know I didn't win a war I was
like I got picked for like in Orchestra
look outside it might be good at the
French Shore and first first screen but
but now it dominates your Wikipedia page
it's really strange and the weird thing
is it's not it's not true that I'm an
accomplished foreign tourists but it is
true like how I got into the Shorin
because of Peter and the wolf this is
why I can't even believe them talking
about this but uh so someone who knows
me has has been like I feel their pride
just like playing a prank I screw with
yeah alright working other pieces of
Wikipedia are true about about you and
one of them is when you were in your
you
think through the framework like should
I do my job or should I go to jail yeah
choice I mean I was in London and the
thing I was obsessing about back then
was LIBOR with there's a huge scandal or
manipulating interest rates and this
would become a book that I was writing
and it was there's a fattening topic of
the stories we were working on was about
list of conspirators that the
prosecutors had kind of compiled and it
might be a details a little wrong it was
basically that the prosecutors had
amassed this list of all these
co-conspirators in this criminal case
they were building and a colleague of
mine and I we were prepared to report
that and that we called the Serious
Fraud Office which is like the main kind
of prosecutor in UK and asked them just
basically gave them a heads-up we were
doing this modest they responded by
telling us that they were going to court
to get an injunction against us
reporting this and the UK doesn't really
have freedom of the best the way we in
America are accustomed to and so
government agencies and individuals to
use injunctions as a way to muzzle the
press and so they had not warned us they
were going toward to get an injunction
and then they called us a little bit
later and said okay as of 4:00 p.m.
there's an injunction against you and it
was like I don't know like 2 p.m. I
guess and so we there's a man you have
two hours yeah and we got to publish it
like 359 and like a little bit was like
moments to go before the injunction
kicked in and ran is before the court
hearing was actually taking place it was
with moments ago and it went online and
then nothing happened and they can't do
anything once it's out there well no
they can they can in fact they did and
we thought there there's a few blissful
hours where we thought this is they were
just gonna let it slide and then I was
at home and I got an email from a
government agency with a PDF attached
saying that there is a court order
naming me specifically threatening me
with contempt of court in jail if we
didn't promptly like delete any
references to this list anywhere and
this was like not great timing for me
personally because I think eight days
previous
my wife had had our first child and so I
was like kind of kind of
on the family that I was even at work
and we had a low tolerance for me going
to jail was it more controversial that
you were at work or that you were being
threatened to go it was so it was just
like it was like pretty bad timing
overall for me my wife was not happy I
was at work and was less happy that I
was seriously entertaining the
possibility of going to jail which
seemed like a low probability event but
stranger things have happened there
anyway there is the the water journal
went to court and fought this and won
and our the injunction was overturned
and but it you know and as these are
relatively low stakes in the grand
scheme of journalism but it's it's a
reminder how good American journalists
have it I mean we can do we just have a
lot more freedom and a lot much greater
legal rights enshrined in the
Constitution there's more protection of
the press
yeah we the presumption in the United
States is that the press
we should err on the side of having a
free press rather than err on the side
of allowing the government or anyone
else to kind of preemptively block the
right of free speech and I mean that's
one of the great things about being a
journalist in the u.s. yeah and so as
you're going through this like you've
got an 8 day old you know child at home
your wife's not super thrilled you're at
work and you get this at any point
you're like oh maybe we won't actually
you know publish this or do you like
turn to somebody and you're like hey
this jail thing for real like yeah I
think through cool I mean initially
there was really no question in the
newsroom and this became like one of
those scenes it kind of felt like it we
were in a movie when they were literally
like running like sprinting across the
news from trying to like beat the 4:00
p.m. deadline and there is literally no
quest and our lawyers were all involved
and they were on board and there's no
question at that point about late should
we beat the government or not of course
we should like it we have it it was
never right to do it we have a right to
do it it was in the public interest and
in some was the fact that government was
fighting so hard to silence is silence
that's Tomatoes yeah and it just you
know we're journalists by nature kind of
anti Authority and so yeah that
encouraged us to publish as quickly as
possible after the fact I mean we had
when I got that letter threatening jail
and
their penalties I mean that is a little
bit of a scarier moment because our
lawyers were like well probably you
won't go to jail but like we can't
promise you yeah you can't promise and
also we were living in the UK with at
like the discretion of the British
government right we're Americans and we
don't have any god-given right to be
living and working in the UK and we very
much liked living and working in the UK
and so that was it was ultimately this
got diffused because there was a quick
court hearing and it was overturned the
injunction was overturned and I don't
know what I would have done given the
choice I mean I would like to say that I
would have gone to jail to stick up for
my rights but like you know I had like I
was madly in love with my newborn son
and like waved you know like going to
jail and principal in a situation like
that one's not a life and death
situation it's not like it's not it
wasn't a question of exposing or not
exposing a source for example which I
would have felt much more strongly about
this was a question of whether I stood
up on principle for the right to publish
things which technically we didn't have
a legal right to do right the law in the
UK is the law in the UK we're Americans
and so we're kind of spoiled honestly
yeah and that I think that's my big
thing is hearing the story is like
there's some stories that are almost
like worth going to jail for right and
then there's some that are like yeah we
have the right to do this like we think
it's a good thing to do but where is the
line and I never sat in that seat so I
don't know how you would think through
that I mean like I don't want to get I
don't want to make it sound like I was
some like murder here this was not a
life and death issue this is not even an
issue it wasn't an important wasn't a
particularly important story and again I
would have felt very strongly about it
if it was there was a source on the line
so if they if I dare Antigua protect
someone's anonymity and the government
was trying to unmask that person I think
I would have I I think I would still go
to jail to protect that person's if I
made a promise or the New York Times
made a promise I would like to think
that I would let go to basically the end
of the world to protect that because
that's something that is
an issue of my personal integrity and
it's an issue fundamental even
journalists being able to do their jobs
properly and I think that's a very
important precedent this was not that
and luckily I didn't get put in a
position where I actually even had to
make the choice ultimately and so thanks
to Wikipedia this is still live is you
years later yeah well I was so I was
telling you the name of the movie is
nothing but the truth which is a a movie
I believe it's rooted in in reality but
there's a reporter Rachel Armstrong who
writes a story that reveals the identity
of a covert CIA operative actually this
is the Valerie Valerie Wright situation
and so if you haven't seen that movie I
highly suggest people go see is pretty
good but in that she does have a source
that she wants to protect and needs to
protect and ultimately thrown in jail
right so to your point of like that's a
little bit different situation than you
were in but it's not without kind of the
jail scenario pointed out in some of
these yeah but I would argue like it's a
it's like it's similar but it's actually
pretty different I didn't that was a
situation where the government was
trying to get some journalists to
divulge a source to whom she had
promised anonymity and that feels like
that is like the most like concrete kind
of ethical or ethos driven part of
journalism is protecting the source well
you hear this over and over and over
again in situations on the extreme side
yeah but they really go to lengths to
protect those source well we need to
right I mean that's it sounds kind of
like a little bit self-indulgent and
kind of precious but it's really
important I mean there's like and we'll
talk about this in a bit I think but and
for the book I just didn't don't you
bank the only way I can write a book
like that or write the stories like that
I did for the times are based on people
taking personal risks to talk to me and
those people for one reason or another
end up believing that it's in their
self-interest to talk to me but they're
doing it based on this assumption that
they can trust me and they trust this
New York Times that I'm not gonna screw
them and it's like that's a vow when I
make that promise to someone I don't do
it lightly and
and again I'm not holding myself up here
this is just yep journalism 101
especially at a place like The Times or
The Wall Street Journal or The
Washington Post and or really anywhere
like any major news organization and I
think I would bet a vast majority of
people of my colleagues that those and
other news organizations there's
basically the same way so it's not this
is not and also like again thankfully we
live in a country where our rights are
pretty well established and generally
pretty well taken care of and and I know
I and I think all of my colleagues are
like grateful on a daily basis that
that's the case and we hope and we'll
fight to make it remain so yeah so part
of that is also like the media has this
role in society and another situation
that you were involved in I think was
people trying to protect that role right
and remain unbiased or the best that
humans can do and so when you wrote your
first book you were invited to go on the
Rachel Maddow Show I'm sure they went on
a bunch of other shows etc but at the
time it sounds like there was folks at
the New York Times who had made a
decision that certain shows were too
political leaning or too biased and so
kind of sells a little bit about how
that play yeah there wasn't my first
book actually that was just with
stemming from some stories in The Times
about Deutsche Bank and Trump and you
know you're writing big stories when
Rachel Maddow I want you to come on just
to talk about the story yeah Maddow has
probably unparalleled reach um in I was
had one kind of half of the political
spectrum and it's like Fox News on one
side her on the other although I would
argue the Maddow again putting aside
putting aside her ideology and her
personal beliefs like Matt was a really
serious journalist and she does her
homework and she calls it like she sees
it but I have a lot of respect for her
as a journalist anyway yeah I was told I
had I and many others of the times had
been on Maddow pretty regularly she
treated the New York Times reporters and
at other news organizations very well
and but she's liberal and she does not
hide that and so there was a The Times
bends over backwards to try to maintain
neutrality on political issues and there
is a decision made by people at the top
of the organization that regular
regularly appearing on opinionated shows
like Maddow or lawrence O'Donnell and
some others as well was kind of risked
that and I somehow got I think was my I
was like had agreed without checking
with anyone because that's what I do
sometimes because I'm stupid and I had
agreed to go on and then it got to back
to people at the times they said no no
you can't do that and that cause like a
bit of a stinger and yeah and look I
mean that I think that was the wrong
decision and one of the great things
about the times is that we can we have
like an open and honest enough newsroom
that you can say I can say I disagree
with Dean BK or you know someone else
and they have enough self-confidence
that they can take that and I think they
listen and it's not like I persuaded
them to change their minds but there was
other people alongside it's frustrating
because there's look everyone agrees we
should be political we should like be
impartial and report without fear or
favor we take that really seriously we
sometimes do it better than others but
like everyone's kind of has the same
goal the question is how do you achieve
that goal best and saying we're not
gonna appear on like Maddow Show because
of perception of political bias is it
from my perspective it just really it's
depriving us in the new york times of
access to this huge like millions of
viewers and Ulta I mean this ban or
whatever was called lasted not that long
in the grand scheme of things and I was
just back on Maddow a couple weeks ago
and I know others happen as well so look
that was I I thought that was the wrong
decision but again I'm very grateful to
work at a place where obviously I'm
gonna respect the decision that gets
made above me but the the leaders of the
times have enough self-confidence that
they will listen to criticism and listen
to people who disagree and change your
mind when they think
yeah-ha-ha balance as a journalist today
just given kind of the social
media-driven world and all the stuff of
like being a person who just it's
impossible for you me or anyone else to
be 100 percent neutral unbiased etc with
the kind of job requirement of I need a
right from that you know without fear of
which they fear that's like a New York
Times saying going back 100 some yes
like how do you balance that and how do
you is it almost like you know when I go
to work I put a hat on that's super
neutral no when I go home I take that
hat off or like like how do you actually
you know it's hard and I don't know what
the right answers and I think different
we were just there's some discussion
about this today in the newsroom it's
like different people have different
approaches some people just don't vote
like they won't even really just try to
like and that's people in our DC bureau
who are much more experienced with this
kind of stuff than I am look I mean we
the times as rules on what you're
supposed to not do like we're not
supposed to me neither I nor my wife
should contribute money to political
causes or go at a March or a fundraiser
or late Oh engaged in any overt
political activity I'm not registered as
either at with any party personally but
look everyone has their opinions and I
think it are I think the ultimate test
we kind of know in our gut if we are
betraying bias in a bad way or at least
I feel like I do maybe my judgments
probably not 100% but like you know we
need in it really it ultimately comes
down I think more to a gut check on the
stories you're working on than anything
else people do stupid tweets all the
time I know I do and generally if you
have to like ask yourself if I should be
tweeting something you should not be
tweeting that then but I feel like
there's certain industries where if you
have to ask yourself you should tweet it
magician even if you're like agonizing
like if you didn't think you need to ask
a colleague if you should you shouldn't
like and it's I've learned that the hard
way
over the years so have you had dumb
tweets oh my god really okay well and
what's the one that you feel most
comfortable talking about that you're
like man that was stupid I don't even
have any
idea where to begin there's this so many
stupid things I've tweeted like there
look we the Trump administration started
frankly even before the Trump
administration started the during the
Trump campaign that was now is
shattering everyone's understanding of
what was normal and I think was really
including me personally and including I
think probably 99.9% of journalists and
pride most of the public - and it was
very hard in those early days of the
Trump administration to like see things
that were extremely abnormal whether his
Trump and Sean Spicer lying about the
crowd size or like this I don't even
really remember it seems like decades
ago but there was we all just speak for
myself I struggled to find the right
balance between like making a point
where I thought a public figure is lying
and making a point where I want to kind
of feel good about standing up on a
pedestal myself and just like preening
for this like kind of circular odd you
know the insular audience you're talking
to and it's just like I don't know I
think their battles worth having in
battles that just make it seem like
you're preaching to the choir and
there's nothing to be gained from
preaching to the choir it's really
interesting a lot of people that have
come on kind of talked about media in
general they usually are not at New York
Times Wall Street Journal etcetera
they're usually building kind of more
than New Age media models and one of the
things that has been hotly debated in
other episodes is kind of this balance
for a journalist today of you want to
write stories that people read right you
want to be accurate you want to tell
certain stories but also the mediums at
which you do that the ways you do that
evolve over time right so literally used
to write on a typewriter now you get
write on a computer like if there's
technology advancements but also the
distribution models change and so
Twitter for example is a great way to
distribute those stories and I've had
people who come on and say like the
downfall of mainstream media is every
journalist must be a blogger now right
and kind of the degradation of some of
those things but at the same time
there's people who will come on and
literally say the reason why the media
still exists in the form factor it does
is because all of those journalists have
taken some of the best things that
bloggers innovated on and incorporated
them but kept that framework of you know
kind of not having prejudice etc like
you sit inside one of those newsrooms
how do you guys think about it I mean I
think there's I think it's not like a
monolithic thought you know there's
different people and I think this
cleaves primarily along age lines okay
okay so it makes sense yeah I think the
older you are the more likely it just as
a general rule the more likely you are
to Hue it to journalistic the more rigid
journalistic standards of objectivity
meaning we don't take sides and we don't
call it right and wrong or like very
reluctant to call us call a lie a lie or
you know obviously one of the new places
where that's really popping up is with
race and I think there has been
historically in white male-dominated
newsrooms of great reluctance to call
racism racism and I think that one of
those things that's starting to change I
think it's I think the younger
generation and I'm kind of somewhere in
the middle probably the younger
generation is has this a very different
vision of the appropriate role of
objectivity in a newsroom the I think a
lot of younger people view that
increasingly as something that
perpetuates bias in actually in much
more pernicious ways than just being
honest about what your own personal
views are and look I mean I don't
actually know what the answer is to this
I don't actually there is like what is
your area you know in part because
different audiences want different
things I mean one of the things the
times has been doing a lot more of
recently which I personally like is
writing more in the first person
and so which allows the reporter to just
be a little more honest about where
they're coming from sometimes and it
allows you to embrace and be transparent
about whatever personal biases you might
bring this it's not necessarily about
politics right it's a and I did a story
of several months ago about this guy Val
Brooks MIT who is and one of the big
whistleblowers in my book and there was
I wrote that in the first person and Val
has been like a very difficult source to
me over the years and he's an
on-the-record sources I was free to
write
and it allowed me in ways that you know
I thought of it especially the time were
very helpful allowed me just be honest
about the great frustrations I had
dealing with him and it also just will
the the great strengths and great
weaknesses he had as a source and so to
me the I guess the paramount priority
for journalists is honesty mm-hmm and
they're many and like we you know
honesty in your gut but being sometimes
writing in the first person allows you
to just be as transparent than normal
with readers because everyone has
opinions and there's no getting away
from that yeah before we get into the
book because the book heavily relies on
Trump and all of his dealings etc what's
it like being at the New York Times when
he's firing away about the quote-unquote
failing New York Times and kind of like
actually attacking your employer and
sometimes even your colleagues except
you're like how do you like is it is it
almost like a joke internally at this
point or is it more of like damn well
will this ever end it is more good again
and I'm probably not the best person to
ask this but just from my perspective
it's it's there's two rations I have one
is that it's surreal I mean this is the
President of the United States and it
used to be the case that it was very
rare to hear the president opine on
anything that relates to you right like
it would be a huge honor generally or
maybe dishonor depending on the context
to to have a president talking about a
story you wrote and now it's become just
that's par for the course if you write
something negative about Trump that's
very prominent you were not likely but
there's like a decent chance you're
gonna get yelled at on Twitter and but
to his what are 60 or 70 million Twitter
followers and which is surreal and it's
like a little nerve-wracking at times I
mean I think the bigger thing though is
that it's I'm glad at the Times and
other news organizations too are in such
a position of strength right now like
The Times is not failing like we're
doing better than we've ever done we
have huge growth and subscribers and
we're doing great and it would be a lot
harder to stomach attacks of us failing
and just generally being bad if we
weren't doing so well I'm just an
objective finance company went to work
every day and it wasn't going well then
someone's kicking you while you were
down that would soft right but as it is
like he's just wrong when he says we're
failing I know he knows he's wrong and
there's it's nice to work at a news
organization that is succeeding yeah so
to do the book you did over 200
interviews maybe just start with like
what was the premise for doing this and
then also you didn't take book leave to
go write the book you were doing your
job and writing at the same time so
maybe kind of walk us through like how
all this played out and how we get the
book yeah
it was very stupid Cleve that was a huge
mistake in retrospect and one that I
will not be making again as long as I'm
married to my wife so the book is called
just so everyone knows the book is
called dark towers Deutsche Bank Donald
Trump and an epic trail of destruction
you wrote this how long did it take it
took the writing process took about two
years okay so two years of writing this
book while working it just came out in
February yep right and what was the
genesis for even going after this story
with it somebody just came to you or now
I mean I back I've been obsessing about
deutsche bank for a really unhealthy
length of time I got to London with the
Wall Street Journal back in 2010 and at
the time the financial crisis was just
ending but the European financial crisis
was just starting up and there was
Deutsche Bank the one of the probably
the biggest bank in Europe at the time
which had these just deep and tractable
problems that kind of everyone was
talking about or whispering about but no
one really knew how serious it was and
so I immediately gravitated toward that
as an important story but never really
got a whole lot of traction but my
colleagues and I spent a lot time
digging into deutsche bank it was this
great black box then everyone was kind
of scared of but no one really fully
understood
in January of 2014 one of the banks
senior executives a guy named Bill
Brooks met who was an American and had
been he had been at the bank for on and
off for like almost 20 years he's kind
of known as the conscience of the bank
he was like a good guy a risk manager
with a real solid ethical compass he
committed suicide in London and I my
colleagues and I started digging into
the circumstances of that it seemed we'd
heard a lot of rumors about the why he
had done that and I ended up talking to
Val Brooks met his son and it went on
this kind of journey or with I've had a
ringside seat as Val went on this
journey to understand why his father
committed suicide and in that process
Val got all of his father's email files
and there's a ton there was thousands
and thousands of documents emails
spreadsheets meeting minutes related to
Deutsche Bank and so and we started
writing about that at the journal at the
time although we didn't say where we
were getting this stuff why did have
like how did he'd get the emails he just
requested and they gave it to us it was
no so his dad had been using his Yahoo
and Gmail accounts for enormous amount
of work emails which is obviously not
normal probably not allowed but they
can't really stop all yeah I think
there's a little more complicated
because he was on this outside oversight
board of the bank and he had actually
retired six months earlier for one
reason or another he had just reams of
emails and son just logged in yeah his
son got his email his login information
and started exploring and Val is it a
complicated character and who is and was
not an expert in finance and I kind of
helped him understand some of the stuff
in there and certainly helped him figure
out what words you should be searching
for in the search field yes so it and
again that was a very interesting
journey but it never really got to the
point of being a huge story in part
because the stuff Val found was
interesting and we wrote about it but it
wasn't earth-shattering and then in
November of 2016 Trump got elected
president and all of a sudden
the Deutsche Bank story went from being
one about a European bank that's in a
lot of trouble and isn't well run and it
became a story of how this random
european bank had essentially helped
elect the 45th President of the United
States and at that point the story went
from being something that was a business
story to one there was an international
very hot international story and so I
kind of started at that point thinking
about all the stuff had been gathering
as how to what was the most ambitious
way to do it and it even at that point
it took another year or two before I
really kind of figured out that this is
something I want to spend a couple years
doing as a book got it and so as you're
going through it the Deutsche Bank
history I didn't know until I knew that
you were to come and sort of looking at
it
it's fascinating I mean this is a really
small Bank at one point that decides
they're gonna go on this global March
for domination right yeah and some of
the things that I didn't know they
probably stands out the most is they
helped finance the Nazis during World
War two including financing the building
of Auschwitz yeah right and like is that
they know that this is bad and they're
still doing it or is it more of like at
the time nobody knows that Nazis are bad
like you didn't look like I had really
well definitely not his revenge well
what I'm saying yeah but how do they
explain it away to yourselves
rationalize it I guess well I mean the
history here is that deutsche bank was
founded in 1870 so this is kind it's one
hundred and fiftieth birthday this year
oh wow
happy birthday Deutsche Bank and they
were founded as a bank that was supposed
to be helping big German companies kind
of spread their wings internationally
and this is the dawn of the industrial
era so like companies like Siemens for
example where relied on Deutsche Bank
for global financing and and it was
really the bank pre World War two is
really synonymous with the German kind
of corporate sector and so the Nazis
come to power in the 30s and they like
other big German companies very quickly
became
okay the corporate wing of the Nazi
Party and in Deutsche Bank's case that
meant everything from financing the
construction of concentration camps like
Auschwitz to financing the factory that
manufactured poison gas for us wits to
taking over Jewish run businesses all
over Europe and getting the Jews out and
bringing it was a process called Aryan
ization and they even took the gold the
Nazis extracted from Jews teeth and sold
it internationally so the bank look the
thing I would say in fairness to the
bank is that there's not didn't really
like it was a choice between colluding
with the Nazis and being driven out of
business the thing I will say not an
offensive Deutsche Bank is that they
were a party to genocide and that's not
a good thing deep thoughts yeah
well sir there's a movie on Netflix
called the resistance banker that I
watched actually Keith were voice I
think was the one who told me to watch
it and it's all about
during the same time periods basically
citizens getting together and providing
literally underground financing to fight
back against these people who empower
and so it sounds almost like in some
sense they were you know basically
counterbalancing the deutsche bank so
the world yeah I mean it's not really
the Deutsche Bank's or the world
Deutsche Bank was the primary financial
enabler of the Nazis as they laid waste
to Europe and as they killed in tens of
millions of Jews and others and this is
the bank the u.s. described deutsche
bank after the fact as a war criminal
its leader was tried and convicted of
being a war criminal the leader of
Deutsche Bank yeah oh yeah and then he
was reinstated as the leader of Doge a
bank and like remained at the top of the
Deutsche Bank for a decade and a half
afterwards and and look again in
Deutsche Bank's defense that's [ __ ]
crazy
sorry it's like crazy that is the
history of this bank is in if you look
at the bank over the past century the
bank has a criminal enterprise it it
participated in the single worst
criminal event of the 20th century which
was the Holocaust and
it didn't just participate it was a the
Holocaust would have happened without
Deutsche Bank
but Deutsche Bank allowed the Nazis to
be much more efficient and ruthless and
what they were done and there's no
there's no way around that mm-hmm
Deutsche Bank would defend itself saying
a that everyone was doing this is that
what you think first of all has
apologized so they get credit for that I
guess and look after the war they the
bank became one of the leading forces
for European reconstruction and
redevelopment which is a good thing and
but I mean there's just no getting
around that original sin there's no
getting around it so another part of
this in the description for the book is
that the bank was quote manipulating
markets violating international
sanctions to aid terrorist regimes
scamming investors tricking regulators
and laundering money for Russian
oligarchs and those are all different
situations and that's not it yeah that's
that's an incomplete list yeah and so
like as you're writing this book it
really is kind of a history of Deutsche
Bank as much as it is some of the
political stuff etc like what what are
you thinking as you're uncovering kind
of each one of these things and is it at
at some point you're just like like what
else could they have done yeah it's a
pretty long list of things yeah and
that's again that's a partial list
uh-huh I was thinking that I've covered
finance for fifteen or sixteen years and
this is the worst Bank I've ever seen
really yeah I mean without any doubt
honestly and I have covered some bad
banks how much of this is I'll call it
pre my birthright so I was born in 1988
so like people who are listening to this
who are my age or older or observer
younger saying that stuff happened way
before I was around like that's the way
everything happened you know before I
was born
versus like this to happen like five
years ago ten years ago yeah this is
stuff of most of this and not all that
most of it is definitely very much in
your adult life so there's a bad [ __ ]
that happened before still bad [ __ ]
happening now yeah I mean look it's all
on there's like a spectrum of badness
right I mean the worst thing Deutsche
Bank has ever done was finance the
Holocaust nothing that they've done
since then
or anyone has done since then really
compares to that and it's kind of
evilness I don't think that was before I
was born
yeah me too me too I although you are a
lot younger than me sorry I look old
since I you had your hair there it
listed probably not for long so I'll
enjoy like it there aiding of terrorist
regimes violating sanctions laundering
money manipulating markets bribing
public officials evading taxes tricking
customers and regulators that's all
stuff that's happened in the past decade
okay and the it's stuff that continued
look the banking industry has been a
very badly behaved industry in the past
10 or 20 years and there's no getting
around that and I think there's a
tendency at least for me or there had
been tendency to just think well banks
behave badly that's kind of like it's
almost like the cost of admission to
being a bank yeah exactly
and this dodgy bank took it to an
extraordinary level that I'd not
previously seen and there is every bank
every major international bank has been
involved in scandals over the past 10 or
20 years the og Bank was at or near the
center of just about everyone and that's
pretty extraordinary I mean this is the
there's something very rotten with the
bank's culture for a very long period of
time that led to that and and one of the
things I've tried to do in is not just
have this be a litany of like evil [ __ ]
the bank has done but it's I've tried to
use kind of construct a narrative around
it that actually it with human beings
being the ones making decisions as
opposed to a faceless institution so and
that that's kind of one of the things
that I care most about that people get
out of this book which is that yes
banks do bad things all completely many
companies do bad things but this is not
this is not like a blameless just fact
of life this is a result of decisions
very clear decisions that humans made it
a very at the very top of the bank over
and over again that had you know
especially with hindsight very
anticipate about consequences which was
that it the employees were going to go
to these great lengths to make as much
money as possible as quickly as possible
winces be damned and if that meant
violating the law or being immoral or
unethical so be it
yeah one of my questions was gonna be
one like how high the awareness or poor
decision-making goes it sounds like all
the way right up to the top
especially in kind of the Nazi situation
literally war criminal yeah but even but
the Nazi situation let's put that aside
B's that I mean again that's yeah that
was awful
yeah but but even the last ten years
yeah I think in some ways comparing
everything that a Nazis makes the other
stuff seem trivial by comparison because
it isn't revealed by comparison but this
stuff in the past ten years or 20 years
is not it's not like the CEO of the bank
was saying please commit like crimes you
know but the CEO of the bank was saying
we need to maximize short-term profits
every quarter we I don't care about next
quarter or next year I care about this
quarter right now the CEO at the time
Joe Ackerman set in 2002-2003 he said he
wanted profits to basically go up 500%
in a period of two to three years and
that's me too exactly and you know what
they did it and oh they did they did it
and the reason that they did it is
because they and then he wanted to go up
even more and they did that too and the
way they did that was by just going
stepping on the gas and just maximizing
short-term profits over and over again
and just kicking tough decisions down
the road not investing in things like
technology or which sounds kind of
technical and like not like that
important but Deutsche Bank to this day
has hundreds of different computer
systems that don't talk to each other
and so if you were to ask a simple
question at Deutsche Bank like what is
your exposure to Russia right now
there's no answer they can't think
that's a banking industry why'd you
think it's a Deutsche Bank issue they I
mean yeah like a lot of banks have
technological problems for sure
Deutsche Bank has just as a matter of
policy did not invest in any sort of
upgrades to their computer systems no
sort of integration of computer systems
and they've now got I mean it's a
multi-billion dollar project now that
they've basically got to start from
scratch and they didn't invest in
compliance and so you've got a huge
compliance
anti-money laundering staff down in
Jacksonville Florida for the bank that
is I mean I was just down there last
spring and summer talking to people
there and to a person I spoke to like
they feel like they're being set to fail
because the interests of the bank that
they're getting from their bosses and
their boss's boss are that we needed to
churn through transactions we don't want
people saying no and again the
consequences of this are in the
short-term it's profitable because doing
as much business as possible tends to be
profitable in the short term in the
medium to long term it's disastrous
because you end up laundering money for
people at helping people evade taxes or
commit bribery and then you get in
trouble for it and we say oh look it's a
bad cluster of employees here a rogue
person here when in fact it is the work
of an institution and very top
executives of the bank setting setting
priorities and creating a culture that
is deliberately designed to foster this
really reckless mentality when you said
that you were down there like does the
bank invite you in and roll out the red
carpet and they're like hey nice to see
you again
in fact for some reason I didn't think
they would you know it's funny the bank
that my Jacksonville trip I think was
like probably last May it was funny look
I had a pretty good relationship and
still do with some of the bank's PR
people who are trying to do their jobs
and they're not high up in the
organization and I respect them and I
think they respect me most of the time
at least they respect me and I respect
them but they I was down there and just
in advance had been contacting I
probably hundreds of people on LinkedIn
I'm just trying to set up meetings and
you know you get this is one of my
favorite tactics as a journalist is you
just flood the zone with LinkedIn
requests for a company like this and you
get a very low head rate okay maybe five
percent maybe even less than that but if
you sent out 200 feelers that's 10
people 10 people and that's great so I
was down in Jacksonville and met or
spoke with about 20 people and it but I
got a busy on LinkedIn before you I was
I got back and and I taken great pains
while I was there to concede I wasn't
like tweeting or Instagram or doing any
that was keeping a low public profile
because I didn't want the bank to know
I was you know literally in their
backyard snooping around talking to
their employees and I got back and I
somehow ended up on the phone with one
the banks very nice PR people and
they're like so how was Jacksonville and
I was like wow what how did you know and
it turned out that the ninety five
percent of people who I wanted to yeah
exactly
which was I guess kind of naive of me
that I thought that wouldn't happen but
yeah and so like as you're writing this
one of the things that I read was the
CEO Joe Ackerman I think is the name had
a really interesting relationship with
the Russians yeah talk to us a little
bit about that and there's like a job
offer at some point or it kind of how
does all that play out so Deutsche Bank
it in general is a really interesting
relationship with the Russians ain't
going dancing everyone has anyone who
hasn't relationship with the Russians
has a really interesting really enjoyed
Jew Bank has probably more of a
relationship historically with Russians
than any other non Russian bank and it
goes Badgers to finance and railroads
for the Czar in the late 19th century
and don't you back took great pride in
being kind of the premier western bank
it basically in Russia basically without
interruption for well over a century uh
and Ackerman as he did with many things
took this to an extreme and he really he
found Russia fascinating and he want to
be big in Russia he wanted to be big in
a lot of a merchant market to the Russia
to him was this just great frontier of
banking and he cultivated
very senior people in Russia and
including the CEOs of some of the
state-owned Bank I'm including one VTB
that is as very close links to what had
been the KGB cultivated very close ties
with Vladimir Putin and so much so that
when Ackerman retired as CEO back in
2012 Putin met with him and personally
offered him a job working for the
Kremlin which is pretty unusual that's
not happen every day I'm assuming it
doesn't happen every day and it's really
unusual for a non Russian person to get
an offer like that much even more so for
a non Russian they sent his entire
career working for like these big
capitalist banks and it was an
indication of just how close Deutsche
Bank and the Kremlin have gotten in the
Ackermann years and that was a
relationship that was very profitable
for Deutsche Bank and also ultimately
got the bank in a lot of trouble because
as they were doing all over the world
they were really pushing the envelope in
Russia in some cases violating the law
yeah so they obviously have this
interesting relationship with the
Russians they've got one that's pretty
interesting with Donald Trump as well
talk to us a little bit about that so
deutsche bank back in the late 1990s
made this fateful decision that it no
longer wanted to be just a german bank
or a european bank it wanted to get on
Wall Street and and in the City of
London and the way to do that they
basically tried to build from scratch an
investment bank which is hard righty
there's like big established players
that are already out there and it's not
just building it we got to compete with
others that are already much bigger so
they spend billions of dollars hiring
thousands of people especially from
Merrill but other firms as well and one
of the things they did was tried to
build up in the US a commercial real
estate business that was going to be
packaging some real estate loans into
mortgage bonds and then selling less on
to investors which in the late 90s was
one of the kind of hot new fads on Wall
Street how did it turn out in the late
2000s so not although enjoyed the bank
again like this story is so weird to
throat um because Deutsche Bank had a
pretty good crisis they shorted the US
housing market more effectively than
just about any other bank with the
possible exception of Goldman anyway
that's a story for another day but
there's one of the basically they
weren't gonna go for
murrs in the US who were well
established and already had good
relationships with other big banks
because why would they write like why
would if you're a big established real
estate tycoon you don't have any bank in
the world kind of on speed-dial ready to
serve you up loans so they need to go
for kind of second or third tier players
the way one document person described to
me is that they would go for the scraps
and at the time Donald Trump was was it
scrapped and he had defaulted over and
over again on his company's debts he was
unbanked belen Wall Street because of
that and because he was did not have a
reputation as a very serious person and
deutsche bank so a bank needed done
bankable clients and Donald Trump was a
none bankable client and so it's a kind
of a match made in heaven and so
starting in the 90s Joy's bank started
making hundreds of millions of dollars
of real estate loans to Trump in his
companies and over the ensuing two
decades dispensed about two but more
than two billion dollars of loans or
debt to Trump and that was despite the
fact that Trump over and over again
defaulted on his debts including to
deutsche bank and so you'd have these
just wild situations where one arm of
deutsche bank would say make a six
hundred million dollar loan to trump
from with default on the loan soo
deutsche bank and then find another part
of the bank in this case the private
banking division to come in and restart
the relationship with Trump lend him
money so he could repay the other arm of
deutsche bank to whom he had defaulted
and they would just restart the
relationship this happened on multiple
occasions and you know I've covered Wall
Street a long time and I've more
important I've talked to a gazillion
people on Wall Street in the banking
industry and this is not normal practice
it's one in general generally when you
default on your loans especially when
you do it in a way kind of this
scorched-earth way that Trump was doing
where he was not only defaulting but he
was suing the bank okay going on the
attack against the bank that is a very
good way to end your relationship with a
bank and lo and I've been understandably
and lo and behold in Trump's case
Deutsche Bank was so eager to keep
winning business and really so eager to
each individual division was so eager to
maximize its short-term profits that
they would look the other way
and this is a thing where they were
doing it with a bunch of other clients
as well that summer situations bad
credit or on bankable as you described
it or was this a specific you know had
two or three individuals and that was
pretty much it and that everyone else
was quote-unquote good and it's taken
there from other banks no I mean they
were doing this a lot and and the other
classic examples I have no I'd never
really heard of before that aren't that
important the other classic example this
though is Jeffrey Epstein so I wanted to
talk about Jeffrey Epstein well here we
go so Epstein was obviously convicted of
sex crimes back in 2008 and somehow
managed to remain a valuable client of
JPMorgan thinks in large part to senior
executives at the bank had these
personal relationships with him but by
2012-2013 even JPMorgan had decided that
this was he was too toxic and he had a
very even though he hadn't been accused
of anything new he had a very well-known
reputation all over the world and
certainly on Wall Street for you know I
don't have any a good yeah not being a
good dude and it's not just the fact
that he appears to have been raping
girls and sex trafficking but it was
also that he was widely suspected
engaging and money laundering activity
for some of his clients and while he's
never he was never accused of that
officially that there were lots of
rumors about that and that's not the
type of client that real serious banks
want to do business with him so JPMorgan
in 2012-2013 severed ties with him and
that left Epstein in this predicament
because he has hundreds of millions of
dollars in assets some of which are in
cash and he has all these shell
companies he's been using to do weird
stuff with his money for many years you
need a bank and these are offshore so
you need a bank a international bank
that's gonna be able to help you deal
with this and does he turn to Deutsche
Bank and Deutsche Bank is not only
initially willing to do business with
him but sticks with him for ain't up
until the middle of last year basically
so right shortly before he was arrested
and charged again and then commits
suicide
Deutsche Bank was the
we Bank willing to touch of it and it's
what are they doing without they giving
them loans or just banking them really
both it was their lending him money they
were managing their doing wealth
management services and I think probably
most importantly but also most opaque so
we don't have a full story in this yet
they were providing all sorts of
transaction services and account
management services probably shell
companies he had where he was moving
money on behalf of himself and I think
other people into basically offshore tax
havens and just jurisdictions where
there's even less transparent
got it and what I understand from the
Epstein and I'm by no means an expert or
really haven't spent too much time
looking into it is there's two general
thought processes that who he was and
his importance in the world one was
here's a money manager who's got a bunch
of really wealthy clients and kind of is
more the clean image right in terms of
there's the criminal activity but
Formica business perspective was just a
money manager who's investing etc then
there's this world of like know there's
this whole like blackmail ring and the
money laundering and on top of that all
of the underage girls and sexual assault
etc it sounds like there's evidence or
records that would suggest the second
example is much more accurate than the
first well I think it's not a question
of accuracy it's more question of
probabilities and so these look Epstein
was convicted or was charged but not
convicted of vast array of sex crimes
and I think based on the reporting that
The Times and many others like the Miami
Herald have done you know if you're
asking me like he pretty sure [ __ ] did a
lot of bad stuff the question is whether
on top of that he was also providing
money laundering services or
blackmailing people or things like that
and we don't know is the bottom line
there's there are a bunch of
investigations into what he was doing
with his and other people's money he
certainly managed to win the confidence
of some very powerful wealthy people
whether it's less Wexner who is the CEO
of L brands or Leon black from Apollo or
Jess Staley who's now the CEO of
Barclays and had been at JPMorgan for
many years and there was a group of
people who should have known better and
the most generous interpretation is that
they didn't know better yeah
and through this we are unlikely
oh yeah I mean Deutsche Bank has records
of what he was doing this money yeah
there do you get them I don't know if I
knew the answer I mean I have some ideas
but you can share well look I mean the
argument I would make to Deutsche Bank
is that this is their bank right now
that has a very very bad reputation and
yet their current management is new and
I think is making an honest effort to
repair that image and move recently and
long ago and how do you how do you win
back the public's trust after you've so
clearly betrayed it over and over again
well I would argue that one good way to
do that is to take an example something
you've done
that allowed something very bad to
happen which is Jeffrey Epstein and come
clean about it you know help the world
better understand that the world you
your institution played and allowing
this to happen and at the same time do
provide a public service of shedding
light on something that's very opaque
right now and so look I mean we'll do a
bank by that argument I don't know
anyone from Deutsche Bank is listening
or watching you should buy that argument
yeah I mean Goldman just did this right
with the 1mdb type stuff like they
definitely didn't walk out and say like
hey here's everything we did wrong but
there was a little bit of scapegoating
where there's certainly who got arrested
charged you know all this kind of stuff
I think there's even people barred from
a financial inertia I don't all the
details right but just there was some
punishment to individuals but the bank
itself to some degree has said yes we
did participate in this I don't think
that they were forthcoming yeah I feel
like Goldman in the 1mdb case has done
that in a pretty half-assed way to be
honest with you like they've done it in
a way where they're very Pro Goldman way
in a pro Goldman way right they're like
they're throwing lower-level employees
under the bus and they are denying very
staunchly any institutional
responsibility in a legal or just moral
sense and look they're under criminal
investigation and I guess that's what
you do but in Deutsche Bank's case with
this I mean look you talk to people
inside Deutsche Bank up and down the
food chain and they're just happy
plactic about the fact that their
institution was providing these services
to someone
as bad as Jeffrey Epstein up until and
quite recently less than a year ago and
that is something that they are I think
mortified about and they genuinely I
think a lot of them feel badly about it
and would love to be able to wash away
that stain and the argument I would make
to them and I know yeah I I would make
to them I don't know if any idea if
it'll be effective is that one good way
to watch you know some sunlight is the
best disinfectant absolutely you think
he killed himself
I know that the coroner has said that he
killed himself I there are a lot of
people that don't believe it
it's man both of those are true
statements and I don't know is the short
answer I mean I the by the way I don't
know either
no no one but to me it's like one of it
if there's a mystery that I think sums
up like 2019 2020 it's this i but in
also though it sums up the way the the
the way that many Americans have just
lost faith in public institutions to
tell the truth right the fact that and
again I don't know what the truth is
here there's what I I guess my argument
would be that there's mmm there could be
a conspiracy without him having been
murdered like somehow he managed like
those again I'm not an expert on this
either but the two guards like fell
asleep or was not paying they could have
simply allowed him to commit suicide and
that is the conspiracy rather than he
got murdered yeah and I don't know I
mean there look I don't know I have no
idea whether all I know is what the
coroner said and that I know that his
fan some of his family and many others
doubt what the coroner said but one
thing that is for sure is that there are
a number of extremely powerful people
who have been this for all intents and
purposes unlimited money
who quite possibly had a lot of reason
to be concerned about what Epstein might
have said to protect himself and the and
he was
working with and socializing with some
of the world's a number of the world's
most powerful wealthiest people and had
been doing so over a period of years and
there is I have no doubt that he had
dirt on some of them in fact he the a
year before he died one of my colleagues
Jim Stewart at the times went to his
townhouse and they an interview tonight
he was in his town us and Epstein was
gonna boast to him at the dirt he had on
powerful people and we wrote about this
so this is in the public domain and but
this is a man who that's wild
yeah it is wild the the absolute story's
crazy and I I mean this is what I've
been working on these stories with some
of my colleagues over the past year and
it's it's wild yeah you also wrote about
the guy who came forward to the
attorneys after the fact like you know
there was a guy who claimed to be a
hacker I think right and he came to to
Petra Kessler it came to two attorneys
and said hey I have all the tape it's
like all these tapes everyone thinks are
out there I have them help me yep and
then these guys went from like defending
the victims 12 something's switching
around and now they were gonna like go
basically blackmail is blackmail right
well I'm probably I don't know blackmail
is a particularly GLE meaning that we
definitely were not comfortable using in
our stories they were our reporting show
that they the lawyers were expressed
eagerness to use any materials that this
guy might have got it to reach financial
settlements with very wealthy people
like the less Westerners of the world
early on blacks of the world and get
money out of them and the point of this
story because actually remember reading
this and it's a bizarre still didn't
know that you were also inviting that
hours book was these lawyers not these
two specific but just lawyers in these
positions that have high-powered clients
and they can kind of choose sometimes to
defend the victims sometimes to defend
yeah the accused etc one sometimes they
try to do both
yeah and they they just they just
navigate this really fine line in life
and we put a lot of trust again in them
doing the right things etc it was just a
fascinating story
because then you overlay it with like
the whole Epstein stuff and you have the
salaciousness of it that was one of the
weirdest stories I've ever worked on and
there's in part because the guy who was
claiming to have these videos and we
don't know his real identity and we have
not know I mean we've met him but like
and talked to him and we he says his
name is patrick kessler but that does
not even he acknowledges that's a fake
name and but you've met him in person
liar show you haven't but my colleagues
haven't we did a like a little
documentary in these sat for it and like
there's yeah so we no one came forward
that saw it and was like oh that's my
brother
no we you that's part of the reason we
did this is yeah thought maybe that
would get him out of the like who we
have no idea this guy he could be the
range of possibilities is like he's an
insane person or he's for real and he
really does have these videos or he's
working to discredit the lawyers reason
working to describe the victims or he's
working to discredit les Wexner and Leon
black or he's working for Israeli
intelligent a think is true is that he
is who he says he is and has what he
says he has because he had no actual
hard evidence of having these supposed
videos of people having sex and Jeffrey
have students properties and that was
kind of his underlying pitch and his
inability or refusal to actually show
the goods made us doubt very much his
yeah his honesty you live a fascinating
life but just like you specifically at
this intersection of kind of the news
and the investigative components in the
finance world just a lot of the players
involved etc or I think people by those
who amassed great fortunes and how they
do it and you know is it legal is it not
legal etc and you spent a lot of time on
those stories I think it's pretty
interesting how you specifically do it
I mean I am lucky to be able to do
something that I love and do it for an
institution that has the resources and
the appetite to do really great stuff
and I'm blessed by the amazing
colleagues I have work around and you
know I feel grateful every day yeah I
was spending a couple of minutes talking
about a bit coin and crypto because I
when I saw that you write in the book
I've been saying I've got the same for
last two years of long Bitcoin short the
bankers and really what it was was more
of like sort short central banking type
monetary policies but of course when you
say that the Twitterverse runs with all
bankers are bad right and so now I've
somehow become like my dm's are filled
every time a bank does something bad I
just get flooded with DMS of like looked
at look at what they did but you also
while you're covering a lot of that and
doing the investigative reporting you
also wrote a piece about the wincle vibe
right and Ben measure exploit cetera
what was your take on like there's like
this new finance world that's getting
built around Bitcoin etc and the
Winklevoss twins and yeah I mean look
that was a review of metrics book which
I like wasn't a huge fan of no I
I mean there's why not I didn't think he
made a good argument for why the wink of
I in particular were in a position of
particular interest honestly like they
from my and I'm not an expert on this
beyond having reviewed a book to be
honest so the thing that was most
jarring and kind of off-putting to me as
a journalist reading a book was a
disclaimer those at the very beginning
of the book which is that it was again
I'm not gonna get this quite right but
there's something to the effect of some
scenes and dialogue in this book are
imagined and to me as someone who
Labor's
like every day to and again I watched my
colleagues doing this I'm so much
respect my colleagues doing this the
painstaking way we try to verify every
word and a story in every quote in a
story in every little fact and the
lengths we go to just like we agonize
over sentences to could make sure things
right
it is so
frustrating to then see someone in a
small print disclaimer at the beginning
of a purportedly nonfiction book by a
serious best on journalist to just kind
of blithely state okay just made up a
bunch of the [ __ ] like that I that
really and Mezrich Scott is following
and I there's nothing I've never met the
guy I'm sure he's great yeah and he's a
podcast look at theirs I have nothing he
also wrote books about aliens so he's
good at my book hey man there's and look
the accidental billionaires his first
book which actually I think had a
similar disclaimer but was like a he's a
really good writer
so here's the one thing he told me which
I actually think plays into this I am
NOT speaking for Ben this is my
assumption so I could be wrong on this
is that he actually a lot of times will
go sell the movie script first so he'll
get the movie deal and then he'll write
the book as wisdom as a way to basically
ensure that there's gonna be move so
accidental billionaires and social
network and in this case same thing
right so the movie script there was a
movie deal done and then the book was
written and so I don't know but my guess
would be that part of this is like
there's a book that's based on true
events but it also is a hybrid into like
a movie script right but I again I get I
hear your point it's like this
old-fashioned stickler in this but it to
me it personally really important
because I see people like the President
of the United States going on labeling
things fake news and our response to
that is that dude you have no idea how
hard like we get things wrong every day
but we try so damn hard every day to get
our facts right in the length we go to
to make sure that there's nothing wrong
and that frankly the way the
transparency with which we correct
things when we do inevitably get things
wrong like that is so core to what
mainstream news as part of its job it's
like pretty frustrating to then see
someone who has this great megaphone
like that Mezrich does go and just have
a complete it's like fine if he's good
not gonna call it nonfiction but
nonfiction means it's anyway this is my
bias and yeah I'm not even trying to
like I guess the other thing you know
I'm not an expert on Bitcoin or the
wincle by just my critique of
the book was that the wink of I came
across to me as like I didn't have that
much like sympathy for them they were
they got in Mezrich Stella got kind of
ripped off by a Mark Zuckerberg on this
idea that they had in college and
Zuckerberg becomes extraordinarily
wealthy but it's not in the window like
it pretty well compensated themselves
and it's like they're getting very
they're getting enormously rich
themselves for an idea there was like
the half-baked college idea and it it's
not like they had executed a plan
perfectly or build a company themselves
they they had a great idea and in their
telling or Mezrich stalling they got
ripped off by Zuckerberg but they got I
can't remember the number is like tens
of millions if not hundreds of millions
of dollars in Facebook stock or in cash
and I think it was tens of millions yeah
and and to me I just like so here here's
my my one pitch to you but that guy just
say that it's not that nothing against
me like nothing against digital
currencies or Bitcoin or anything like
that or Krypton here's the one thing
I'll say about Cameron to Tyler that I
think is underrated so so even after
been kind of did a 180 on their
breakeven it's like hey look yeah I had
one perspective of them not change my
mind in some weird world in the future
if Bitcoin becomes what I think a lot of
bitcoiners believe it will become they
probably go down as the best investors
of our lifetime and the reason being
they may they investment so early in
Bitcoin when it was you know very very
unpopular no one really knew about it
they put millions of dollars into this
thing and then the amount of Bitcoin
that they owned well could be eventually
I mean they could be the first trillion
errors yep right now there's a lot of
what-ifs that have to occur to get to
there etc but to me there's a lot of
people who I think T their perspective
oh if you know if I had fifty million
dollars I would put you know 10 million
owes 100% tote and I'm like if you had
50 million dollars you would spend it
all right you wouldn't be investing in
[ __ ] no and look my critique of this is
not a knock on them at all it's that the
look who knows either Bitcoin or digital
currencies in general are going to
become they're gonna take over the world
or their kind
I feel like I think it's pretty minor
yeah I do I say that from an on I don't
think we're necessarily wrong in that
thought process it at least in the sense
of it the promise of it is very binary
so it's like hey look either this
becomes huge or like it's not important
not important does it mean zero it just
means that it's kind of like every other
asset right exactly and look blockchain
is clearly a technology that is going to
be ubiquitous if it isn't already but
that's different obviously than saying
the currencies will be and look you know
they if their bet is right that's
obviously going to make them there
they'll be hailed as visionaries yeah
rightly so and so when you're doing a
lot of the investigations etc into a lot
of the banks and financial organizations
sector does a this come up like do any
of the employees or anybody talk about
any this stuff or is it really there's
like a boy in crypto world and like it's
a very much eco yeah versus the Wall
Street world it's yeah that I mean you
get executives I'm also paying lip
service to it occasionally but it's look
there's a great fascination with blocks
but they're the blockchain not Bitcoin
crowd which right they get made fun of
by the Bitcoin crowd is that that's like
a 2015 parity but also that's kind of
just the way like I would imagine super
low-risk it was it's low-risk and it's
helpful right it's a great like it's
that is great social value and it may
turn out that Bitcoin and other digital
currencies have great value as well I
don't think it's that surprising that
the mainstream world the mainstream
finance world is not embracing it
because it's kind of an existential
critique of the mainstream finance world
right and I think you get it better than
you're letting on
I mean there's a and I respect that also
this I I don't have any problem like I
you know I don't understand it well
enough
no but you nailed it right it's this
idea that there's an existing system and
there was this creation that really is
the antithesis to the existing system
right it says hey the existing system
has flaws we're gonna correct those
flaws he-she day whoever created it
right and you get this weird world in
the future of either the existing system
wins and this new thing goes away the
thing wins and the existing system goes
away or there's coexistence
so basically got three outcomes and I
actually think you know if you ask
somebody like an angel ross sorkin or
something right he would say that it's
one of the most polarizing things he's
ever seen where you bring a bunch of you
know let's say ten financial executives
into a room that are all intelligent all
respect each other and you ask them what
do you think about Bitcoin and you leave
come back in 20 minutes
500 on one side fiver on the other side
and they literally thin like the other
side is stupid and there are people with
some black eyes that let's go this is
super super polarizing which I think
drives more of the fascination right
it's cuz you have all these really smart
people who so vehement ly disagree on
this one thing and it's like well what
ends up happening and based on my very
limited experience in this world I think
I love the Bitcoin enthusiast kind of
revel in their outsider ISM right and
there's I think again long Heidi coin
short the bankers yeah and I think there
would be some of the fun maybe would be
taken out of it if all of a sudden
everyone was just like okay Bitcoin wins
it's like you know the the point of it
is to kind of give the finger to the
banking world and if banks and there's
some bit I mean look fidelity and others
now we're starting to I think realize
hey look like maybe this is important
right where it's like fifty percent of
their revenue now from Bitcoin I don't
know that I call Bitcoin related
products yeah if I remember correctly
it's like 50 percent of top-line revenue
comes from the Bitcoin related product
but they only did about eight million
dollars in profits so on a percentage
basis profit wise they're still like
less than two or one percent of profits
come from it but from revenue basis it's
huge look the way these things normal
again not speaking about Bitcoin yeah
currencies in at all and I'm in speaking
about banks just in general and my
experience as a journalist the way most
of these kind of likes hyperpolarized
like seemingly binary issues actually
worked out in the end is that they're
not binary it turns out that there's a
lot of shades of gray and outcomes kind
of merge as time passes and again I
don't know enough about going to say
whether that's the case here but there's
I mean it's certainly not the kind of
thing that is certainly at the New York
Times and in the bankers I talk to most
I don't think most of them view it as a
fraud they just like they view it as
like a kind of speculative device that
is popular on the fringes kind of and
that's that maybe one people play with
it the young people and kind of the like
the far right or the far left I think is
kind of the perception which again I I'm
sure is not really accurate and what
defines like a libertarian bent to it
right kind of the self sovereignty and
all that stuff for sure I think like
being dismissive of something that is as
popular and increasingly common as
Bitcoin is that that's a mistake and
it's very easy for people in they're
like you know big towers at a bank or in
journalism or academia to have it look
down your nose at this upstart and just
write it off as like idiots doing this
and that's almost always you know you
get your comeuppance yeah for sure
people can go to Amazon or where else to
buy the book just google it dark hours
dark hours Deutsche Bank Donald Trump an
epic trail descript destruction and
you'll find it and you should buy it
what uh what do you want people to take
away from the book that this is a story
about how the decisions of human beings
can have tragic consequences and not
just for a bank but for companies for
economies for humans so you can see this
now Joe over there has learned how to
put the good graphics over the
yesterday's and all of a sudden now I
see graphics just flying into the screen
both covers everything it must be very
distracting no I just know that he said
on the last episode he's he's gonna be
dangerous now that he has this ability
I'm waiting for him to start putting
memes and everything else out done
committing it is alright to finish up
I've got two questions for you and then
you get to ask me one question to end
what's your favorite book that you've
ever read can't be one of your own
it definitely would not be one of my um
my favorite book fiction or nonfiction
you choose Wow um I think my favorite
not my favorite fiction book is 100
Years of Solitude
okay what about it's a it's a kind of
Allen school
it's very Gabriel Garcia Marquez
it's magical realism and it's about this
village that is it's kind of an isolated
village and weird [ __ ] happens it's a
fiction book it's fiction it's a hundred
years of solid 100 Years of Solitude
it has the best opening line in my
opinion of any book ever written and I
don't I'm not gonna be all to recite it
but it's a wonderful book uh I don't
know nonfiction wise there you know I I
can tell you the best couple of
non-fiction books I've read recently are
midnight and Chernobyl fantastic stay
nothing by Petrograd and Keefe is
fantastic there's a probably the two
best books I read last year awesome
I also have every one about aliens we
think you think they're real you believe
yeah yeah I mean why why because the I
believe as well because the universe is
huge and of course there's like I don't
know what form the aliens take her
whether will receive them but like how
could there not be yeah there's a guy
who who I had on the podcast and he
basically said there's two questions
every human asks what happens when we
die right like is there an afterlife a
lot and to are we here alone and ever
since he asked me that question or he
said to me that framework I'm like those
are the two questions that everyone's
gonna ask so are you gonna ask me what
happens when we die I've never asked
what what do you think you know is
actually scarier to me is not what
happens when we die but actually is
there life here and it's more of this
thing of you know I've asked 230 plus
people this now so I've thought quite a
bit about it but like we actually don't
want the aliens to come here we probably
want to go find them because in this
human history when somebody invades or
discover something I usually doesn't
turn out so good for the people who
first that's that's true on the other
hand you know we've never encountered
anyone from outside of Earth and so
maybe would work differently in look
it's it's so serious that Edward Snowden
in his book he literally says that when
he got into the NSA databases and stuff
one of the things he searched for was
any files on aliens and UFOs and what
did he find nothing well of course
there'd be no files though right and so
it's just super fascinating and today
actually I saw a rendering in four
billion years they say that our galaxy I
saw that it's going to collide yeah and
you start thinking about just the size
of this stuff right and another stat
that somebody sent me was a there's ten
thousand planets I'm sorry I think it's
ten thousand stars that are out there
for every one grain of sand on earth
the universe is a big box really don't
matter yeah well we matter but it's it's
filled with other things that matter
well one question you have for me to
finish up what happens when we die so I
don't know obviously the one thing that
I will say that I'm fascinated by is you
ever read these accounts of people who
pretty much like dying come back they
all tend to be very similar right and
it's almost like this like rewinding of
your life and there's a light and like
all this kind of stuff and I'm not
somebody who's like you know super
conspiracy theorist about in any of it
but I do think that that cohort of
people who have gotten the closest to
death and you know fortunately not died
probably have more to tell us than we
give them credit because everyone else
is frankly full of [ __ ] right like we're
all reading books that you know some
people think are factual some people
think are complete fiction
some people think they're fiction but
still read them because it puts them in
a good you know mental state some people
are like you guys are all [ __ ] crazy
and like science is real I have no clue
but just for whatever he's in that
cohort of people who
you know got very close to death and
came back and say this is what I
experienced they probably got something
going on there yeah it seems like you
know they know more than anyone else
yeah and anyone else who's alive yeah
and also on top of it you start to get
this you know we invested in a company
years ago now that they want a bunch of
awards for freezing and it's sort of
operating so I think we start rolling a
rabbit and then they froze like a pig's
brain or something and when you quote
freeze the brain the way that they do it
and I'm over generalizing is basically
they take cryogenic freezing technology
and deliver it through an oxygenated
process but they're trying to freeze
your brain with a high percent
structural integrity which would in
essence mean that they freeze the
synapse connections
well I swear your memories your
knowledge etc of why so they're like
huge pie-in-the-sky vision would be work
your way up in size of brain all the way
to a human brain if you could freeze a
human's brain then you could actually
either do one of two things you could
basically download all those memories
knowledge etc into a computer so you
know the the kind of ideal state being
imagine if Einstein's brain was around
we could tell them our problems and use
his brain power to help us solve
whatever or to you could do a frank
research right researchers probably more
realistic one but when you start getting
into that world as I was researching all
this then you find out like people are
actually cryogenically getting frozen
you know rich people yeah because they
think in 30 years we're gonna have a
technology that's forever it's fine you
say you're you think aliens may be very
terrifying that is terrifying to me that
terrifies you the notion of people
freezing brains and like being able to
download so yeah that scares the that's
like the scariest thing I've heard today
look it it's a thing though that I'm
actually of the belief like longevity
all the stuff is it will happen you and
I probably will be around for it but
just the arc of human kind of
advancement puts us in a place where you
know I don't know if you were born a
hundred years ago what was the average
expected like maybe 4045 I think it's
probably more than that I guess it
depends where you live right but it but
it's not like we went from 10 to now
we're at you know 75
it was we've probably gained in a
hundred years on a 10 to 20 years
probably and so if you think of it that
way it's like in 300 years could people
be living 220 maybe I don't know but
seems more realistic than the you know
you were I discovering a leas tomorrow
so unfortunately all right guys go get
dark towers Deutsche Bank Donald Trump
and an epic trail of destruction and you
can follow david at david and rick on
enrich and rich oh man see okay you the
CH all right here's one where to say i
get this every day but because some
people when they pronounce their own
name it ends in CH they say k yeah no I
get it you say enriched yep is that the
right way to say it alright go follow
them on Twitter go buy the book and
we'll have to do this again after you
break up more stories thank you